welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston secret invasion is facing its
finale after making its biggest reveal
of the Season that Nick Fury sent a
group of Scrolls into the aftermath of
Avengers endgame's final battle to steal
Avenger blood blood that gravic now
wants in exchange for calling off
America bombing Russian soil of new
skrelos an inciting World War III
culminating in a man on man fight in the
super scroll machine but how will the
series set up Marvel's future in titles
like Captain America Brave New World and
the Marvels which just released its new
trailer I'm gonna explain how this is
going to lead to a red Hulk president
and Galactus gobbling all of us up so I
guessed it in the past week on a few
special episodes of the break room
please check them out as well as my
analysis of Jaws over in the Deep dive
Channel subscribe to all three channels
in the new rockstars Network also
sag-aftra has informed us that
entertainment journalism Outlets like
new rockstars are allowed to analyze
movies and TV shows without violating
in-strike rules this video not a paid
promotion we support the actors and
writers on strike and join their call to
the amptp to come back to the table and
negotiate in good faith okay in the
final minutes of the penultimate episode
of secret invasion Fury returns to a
drop site in Finland and from a
mausoleum he acquires a new coat a gun
an eye patch and a vial containing some
Avengers DNA and he calls someone on the
phone it's time
let's finish this now my assumption is
that he was calling gravic to let him
know that he was on his way to new
skrillos to confront him and his trailer
footage has indicated he will but other
theories have emerged as to who else
Nick Fury might have been calling in
this moment perhaps Gaia who earlier in
episode 5 told him I'll put on a good
face maybe a clue that the two plan to
use her with her super scroll empowered
healing abilities to pose his Fury and
fight graphic stalling graphic while the
real Nick Fury and Sonya fallsworth and
Dr Rosa Dalton activate the Super
Squirrel machine to fry and overload
graphic with some enhanced DNA that he
cannot handle like maybe the overcooked
blood of Tony Stark after he snapped the
Infinity Stones blood that could poison
gravic and leave him as well done as
Tony Stark was I mean how else do you
beat someone who can heal from a shot to
the face and as we see in promo footage
Hulk out to Bruce Banner or call
obsidian level strength but in Fury's
explanation of Sonia fallsworth he
singles out the blood of Carol Danvers
in particular nearly every avenger
spilled blood even Carol Danvers in the
aftermath some were sent in to collect
that DNA nobody knew about them but me
and the collectors led by cracking so
it's possible that Fury was calling
Carol Danvers here after all that's who
he calls in the opening section of the
latest trailer for the Marvels Dale
Danvers
prodigal child of the Milky Way clearly
these two are in touch and he might have
told her to hang back and not interfere
with the Scrolls until this last second
assuming Nick Fury will survive these
events this series will need to
establish how and why Nick Fury ends up
back on the saber space station and what
his current status is with Captain
Marvel and Monica Rambo or you know
maybe Nick Fury called quake and all you
Agents of Shield die hards will finally
have your moment in the sun really the
bigger threat and the reason graphic is
probably okay with the bombing of new
skrillos is that he's actually having
all the Scrolls relocated to remote
super scroll underground gestation Beds
which could be those rows and rows of
glowing beds that Gaia and Sonia Falls
were come across in trailer footage that
we have not seen in an episode yet
whatever happens with gravic the secret
Invasion I think is about to give way to
an open scroll war on Earth Earth is
going to become a hostile war zone
between the out in the open militarized
Scrolls and their longtime imperialistic
Rivals the cree I think this is the
threat facing Earth in the Marvels Cree
General Dar Ben has embarked on a coup
of the cree forces targeting the
Homeworld of to finish a job that her
accuser predecessor Ronan never could
leading all the cree into a United
militaristic force and capturing Terror
leading to the final extinction of the
scroll refugees and the defeat of the
only Avenger that the non-terrans
currently care about I imagine Carol
Danvers Captain Marvel who they call the
annihilator and I think that's why
president ritzen's gonna be inevitably
replaced to the more wartime leader like
President Thaddeus Ross in Captain
America Brave New World somebody's
probably gonna end up being the Red Hulk
summer is the perfect time to travel and
if you want to get the most out of your
trip you're going to want to use Babel
to learn a language before you go
anywhere Babel is one of the top
language learning apps in the world it
is scientifically proven to help you
start speaking a new language in just
three weeks Babel's lessons are designed
by real language teachers your
subscription even comes with two free
live classes Babel's method is simple it
teaches you real world conversations so
you're prepared to have practical
conversations about travel business
relationships and more even if you just
want to let people know estoya
prendiendo espanol por favorable
the Babel subscription might be what you
need if you're really in love with the
language get a lifetime subscription if
you're just flirting with a poor and
tongue there are monthly options
available as well no matter what you
need Babel has you covered click the
link in the description below to get 60
off your Babel subscription today and I
think the corpse of Tiamat plays a
bigger role in this than we think Marvel
has just gone too long without
addressing this and these
upcoming films are the perfect
opportunity team it either to the eyes
of these extraterrestrial races
represents a botched extermination that
resulted in a cosmic imbalance that
other external forces might seek to
correct or capitalize on or really put
Earth in the crosshairs as having a
unique source of celestial minerals to
mine we've talked to the past about team
up being a deposit of adamantium
especially after black panther wakanda
forever a movie that implied that two
different vibranium meteorites must have
struck Earth in the distant past one in
Africa leading to the establishing of
the wakanda nation one in the Gulf of
Mexico leading to the establishing of
swallow Khan a coincidence so
astronomically small that both must have
come from some Divine source that
intended this to happen like the
celestials planting the celestial seed
with Tiamat leading to some of these
deposits on the planet therefore
vibranium and its alloy adamantium might
have a Celestial origin that could be
the battlefield in Captain America 4.
see you much in its why Nick Fury has
launched the saber battle station
protect Earth from outside forces
because yeah you could totally spot that
Stratosphere popper from space so why
did Fury enact operation Harvest not to
protect against skrulls or super Scrolls
because he was still aligned with the
squirrels at that point I think it was
to have a Fail-Safe plan against
anything else out there I think the
Harvest was Fury's first step toward
something like a weapon x program or a
Sentry program just based on trailer
footage for the Marvels Furious Cadets
on this saber space station all have
matching uniforms with a dollar sign
logo which I know it's just an S for
saber with a sword through it but our
man seems to be building an Academy of
some kind all these folks are young it
was hugely important for Marvel Studios
to define the MCU kamalakon as a mutant
in the final episode of Ms Marvel now I
think that mutant Gene is absolutely
part of the cocktail that allowed her to
manipulate hard light like this it's a
genetic status and I think we're gonna
learn she shares with anyone whose blood
is capable of absorbing Cosmic radiation
without boiling like Wanda maximoff
Monica Rambo Carol Danvers maybe Peter
Quill Nick Fury didn't just want any
Avenger blood from operation Harvest he
wanted Avenger blood that contained a
specific X Gene so how does secret
evasion end presumably the death of
gravic but the eruption of all-out war
between skrulls and the cree on earth a
backdrop will see unfolding on the
Marvels as Nick Fury struggles to defend
Earth using a new superhuman protocol so
that Earth's newest most valuable
resource of adamantium on team at Island
doesn't get plundered or Worse sniffed
out from across the Galaxy by a certain
Planet devouring entity who would Now
find Earth to be extra tasty with some
dead Celestial salmon row layered on top
of it hey let me know how you think
secret evasion will end and the general
course of Marvel throughout the rest of
phase five in the Cosmic Landscape And
subscribe to all three our channels in
the new rockstars Network thank you for
supporting us thanks for watching bye
[Music]